like to think of Europe as peaceful
conflict less a place where differences
are resolved in a civilized way but this
place is different
turn gaku Tatiana with this vote today a
new era starts for our country
from this moment officially we have the
Kosovo
[Applause]
Europe has it's darker aspects ethnic
strife religious divides contested
borders Kosovo is all of that it is
permanently on the brink of a new war it
just needs a spark the self-proclaimed
government there wants to appear strong
escalate cashing on ratings voters just
love a good military parade where the
Kosovo is the right place for that
you decide
[Applause]
the Parliament of the Republic Serbia
which is sworn to protect ethnic Serbs
who live in Kosovo is afraid very afraid
that this new army will eventually be
used to target its brethren the ethnic
cleansing Belgrade says that this could
only mean one thing
Kosovo doesn't want peace everything
that pristine a dozen evidently it does
it all with the support of the US and
Britain is against the law
Serbia says even a military intervention
is an option anything to stop this given
that they would have to force their way
past NATO troops permanently stationed
in Kosovo to give you an idea of how
serious they are on the topic of NATO
the Alliance's long wanted Kosovo to
join the process is already underway and
even NATO has called this move and wise
well the transition of the Kosovo
security force is in principle a matter
for Kosovo to decide we have made clear
this move is ill-timed NATO supports the
development of the Kosovo security force
under its current mandate with the
change of mandates the North Atlantic
Council will now have to re-examine the
level of NATO's engagement with the
Kosovo security force why would that be
why would many NATO allies be against
this new army because it risks war in
Europe again no one in that neighborhood
wants a repeat of the 1999 catastrophe
no-one wants the deal with ethnic
slaughter with war crimes genocide and
refugees that is no one who has anything
to lose now more than ever the
government of Kosovo must engage with
minority communities and coordinate
closely with NATO allies and partners as
it begins the ten-year transition of its
security forces the US will be there
with you the United States has been at
it for years prodding an encouraging
Kosovo to raise an army despite every
objection and why not if they do
American weapon manufacturers might have
whole new army to outfit intention
generated could guarantee an American
presence in the area for decades to come
and there's also a jab at China and
Russia which supports Serbia and don't
recognize Kosovo
all in all a failsafe plan sell the
firewood sell the matches convince
someone to spark a fire and then be
there to put it out we discussed
Kosovo's plan to create its own army
with political writer diana johnston
when they should make the army the first
thing is that the US ambassador said
we'll be there with you
whatever that means which sounds like
they could use Kosovo to provoke a war
because United States will be there with
you this is simply a gesture to to
emphasize a Kosovo status as an American
colony because the base there isn't a
NATO base it's an American base and and
you look in Pristina and they're
American flags all over the place if it
came to a crunch between Serbia and
Kosovo militarily because the Kosovo
army wouldn't have a chance so it still
will depend on NATO and then and the
Americans this arm it can't have any
significant military it's simply to try
to attach itself to the Americans and
the Americans are willing to let it
attached itself to the United States
you